thank you
very much berna good evening everyone
and welcome to this
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
on thursday the 21st of january 2021.
my name is councillor vanessa bell and
i'm the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april 2020
in response to the kovids 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please can i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating a wish to raise a point of
order
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions
or any other purpose when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number and keep your
contributions as clear
and concise as possible when invited to
speak
please ensure you turn on your
microphone now if i may ask officers
taking part in the meeting to introduce
themselves
starting with mrs hughes
good evening
performance and governance manager thank
you cheryl
um berna good evening members bernie
casey clark to this evening's meeting
thank you thank you verna are there any
other offices present this evening
no chairman thank you berna
before i call on the clerk to take the
roll call of committee members
can i ask those counsellors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
good evening chairman councillor penny
channel
thank you good evening councillor
channel
good evening um mr chairman
council for carly mays uh councillor
maze i believe you're a committee member
are you not
yes so welcome to you momentarily
thank you berna please can you now carry
out
carry out a roll call of committee
members to confirm who is in attendance
thank you thank you chairman
so i'm here sorry that's councillor
apologies councillor harlan good evening
thank you chairman members i will take
call your names in alphabetical order
starting with councillor bassinger
good evening everyone good evening uh
i'm present
thank you counselor miss a.m beale
yes president thank you councillor b.s
bill
i don't think we have a chance to feel
at the moment
uh councillor bell president i am here
were you on about councillor brian bill
yes i'm talking about council to brian
beale bs bspl
thank you councillor boyce
council boys we don't seem to have
cancer boys either
counselor fleming
president tara thank you sorry berna
thank you
thank you councillor mays
present burner thank you thank you
councilor morley
good evening and welcome thank you thank
you chairman
thank you bernard run onto item 2
apologies for absence and i have the
apologies for absence please berna
yes chairman we've received apologies
for absence from councillor duik
thank you very much so moving on to item
three which is the
minutes of the third of december meeting
2020. it's recommended that the minutes
of the meeting held on 3rd of december
2020
found on pages 5 to 8 are approved as a
true and accurate record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion
please unmute your microphone and state
your name now
do i have any second mate
help some amaze i'll second that thank
you
councillor mays if any member wishes to
raise any matter of accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will
invite you to speak
i can't see any hands so
i will assume that we are okay thank you
so um berna can you advise if any other
members indicated a wish to speak
no chairman thank you burner so
um i will now take the vote taking each
member in alphabetical order
please state for against or abstain or
does the committee wish to agree the
minutes by a cent
members sent my assent
thank you very much so those minutes are
agreed
good evening speaking i'm attending so
sorry for being late
good evening hansonville we're on item
four public participation
and i can advise that we have not
received any submissions from members of
the public
item five disclosure of interest to
disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
knees
need arise throughout the meeting if any
member has an
interest to declare please use the hands
up function now to indicate
and i will advise you to speak
so do we have any hands
i don't see any hands so i will
take that as a no members
so moving on to item six on the agenda
report of the working group on requested
scrutiny items
we move to agenda item six of the
working group
on requested scrutiny items found on
pages 9-16
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the
hands up function within the meeting
chat
i will then come to sorry not the
meeting chat the meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
ms hughes please could you present the
report for us
thank you chair um good evening members
this report is an update on the working
group that was held on the 8th of
december following their appointment at
the 3rd of december committee meeting
the group met first to review the
overview and scrutiny process and
discuss
promotion to wider members and they
agreed their suggestions for this which
is set out at section
3.2 of the report they also reviewed
member forms that have been submitted
which there was one and reviewed the
transformation information
to decide whether it was a matter for
overview and scrutiny
as is the agreed working procedure
following the working group discussion
there are two recommended items for
inclusion into the overview and scrutiny
work plan
which are indicated at a high level in
3.3 of the covering report
we have also developed a standard
template for items being put forwards to
the committee as part of our new working
process this is to standardize the
information that is considered when
agreeing
an item for overview and scrutiny and
this will be included as the appendices
so set out appendix a the first item is
transformation and a review to what
extent the transformation objectives
were achieved and the wider impacts of
transformation on the organization
set out appendix b the second item is a
review of the debt collection process
and policy
and the impact on our residents the
intention is that the lead officer
identified in the appendices will
conduct any investigation agreed by the
committee
and produce a report to bring back and
that the lead member
will be in responsible for ensuring this
keeps to
and addresses all of the committee's
agreed terms as well as receiving
updates on progress
the lead member is suggested to be
separate to those who put forwards the
item
as the pro protocol and working
practices agreed for ons in october
to find that the items would not be pet
projects of members
and therefore the lead member can give a
neutral oversight
for example they would be ensuring the
investigation only keeps to the matters
agreed by the committee
and doesn't add to the remit or queries
that haven't been agreed
the committee could choose to appoint
any committee member to this role
or they could leave it to the chair to
do this role for some items
or they might choose to continue without
a lead member
if they felt the remit was
straightforward for the officer just to
report back directly to committee
the member who has suggested the
scrutiny item will obviously have a key
role in feeding in to the lead member
and at subsequent sessions of the
committee as well as bringing in their
knowledge to the discussions
members are invited to receive the
working group report
and ensure and therefore assurance that
processes are taking place properly
and also to adopt the recommended
scrutiny items
i would also just like to note for the
committee that since this meeting took
place
an additional seven member forms have
been received
and another meeting of the working group
has been scheduled to review these next
week
should any of the items considered to be
relevant for the overview and scrutiny
work plan
they will then be reported back to the
next committee meeting
thank you members um thank you very much
before i continue can i just remind
members that if you do
have connectivity could you please turn
your
cameras on um if you can i know some
people are struggling with uh internet
issues but if that is not
if you could turn your cameras on that
would be great thank you very much
so um the recommendations
as set out within the report are as
follows
it's little one that the report of the
working group activity be received and
reviewed an assurance that the process
for overview and scrutiny is effective
be confirmed making recommendations
where it's not
and little two that the recommended
scrutiny items and their timetable set
out at paragraph 3.3 of the report
and additionally in appendices a and b
be adopted if any member wishes to
second that motion
please unlock unmute your microphone and
state your name
now members
councillor mays
thank you councillor mays now
if i can invite members to make any
comments on the report please
um thank you first of all
i have council morris if i can go to you
please
thank you uh councillor bell um i'd just
like to start by saying
that uh whilst i see the benefits to
having
a uh fresh pair of eyes and hands honest
item scrutiny
i also see the importance of having
someone with a
uh intimate and um expert knowledge on
the mountains of scrutiny
uh the item scrutiny that i have brought
up which is uh relating to
uh vulnerable people and bailiff use
um i've got quite a bit of experience in
i've done the mental gymnastics of it
quite a bit
i would ask that i've been made made
lead counsellor
on this item there's already a couple of
a couple of bits on it that have um
escaped the officer's uh grasp a little
bit
um i'm just gonna pull ups i've only got
one screen tonight
uh and that is one second folks sorry
this tablet is a little bit slow um
that's okay you don't have to be
specific councillor maurice i
completely take your points on board so
don't worry if you're
struggling to locate the uh particular
points yeah this
uh this tablet is no better than a uh a
a
star really um the the main point was
that um
one of the questions was that the
officer would find out what
vulnerability checks we are doing to
ensure that the people we send bailiffs
to are robust enough to receive
goons at the door and uh i've already
looked into that and i've already
explained that to
officers and i believe to most of the
well to the committee
i actually stated that i've looked into
and asked them what vulnerability checks
we're
doing to be told by one of the lead
officers that we don't do any
so we don't need to look into what we
are doing to find out if people are
vulnerable
because we're not doing anything and
that was uh you know quite recent
um the second um thing uh was that the
officers are asking
what debts do we not send pete you know
baileys to and yet again they've missed
the point there because
uh the whole idea of bringing this item
to the overview and scrutiny committee
would be to ensure
that this council do not send
bailiffs to vulnerable debtors
and that is to be found in the tribunals
cultural enforcement act
the taking control of goods legislation
so the point of me bringing this
item for scrutiny is to ensure
that we work alongside and in the spirit
of the law um what i would like us to be
doing
is to find out before we send them in if
people are robust enough to receive them
we basically do a vulnerability check
before
we send bayless in um i'd like just at
this point because
uh there might be some counsellors there
um
filling their trousers um i'm not saying
that we should not use bailiffs
what i'm saying is we should not be
using bailiffs on vulnerable people
we should check to make sure before we
send
bailiffs into vulnerable households
and and basically that if
bailiffs are needed for debtors that
they
should be needed but they should not be
used as a matter of course by this
council
that's the morris thank you i'm sorry i
was going to i was going to stop you
because i think we're in danger of going
into the scrutiny item itself here which
which we don't we don't want to do now
um any other members have a view
i don't see well i have to say members i
i
do have cancer apologies
go ahead please yes sorry
apologies chair um very bad internet
this evening
um i actually think this is um a very
valid point that
councillor morris brings up um he
does have extreme uh good information
and knowledge about this area
um and although i have been nominated as
the lead
i am quite content to give way on this
particular item
uh having said that i would also be very
interested
in any outcomes as i too believe that
vulnerability is not being looked at uh
in the right way
um either there are things that i've
been involved with
um and i would definitely agree with
councillor morris on this particular
point
thank you thank you very much
and just don't worry i'll be shouting it
from the rooftops mate
thank you both um i have to say yeah i
concur with
councillor morris's view this um
whilst i do i can understand the the
concept of a neutral member
for me this is not an efficient way of
working
it seems to place another layer of
bureaucracy
in the way of work getting done
and whilst i accept i accept cheryl's
point about
pet projects my belief
is that the working group system will
prevent that
from happening and in relation to the
other points
for me again it's about a robust
procedure
that is followed correctly and if we do
that
members which i believe we are more than
capable of of doing
then i think it makes absolute sense to
have someone with
both a passion and knowledge
lead on individual scrutiny items where
i work if someone has a particular
interest in something they're
nominated champion and it's their role
to
then educate the rest of the uh the team
about that issue
let's not get bogged down in bureaucracy
let's focus on on
getting the work done so i'd welcome
any views again on this caster bassinger
has
raised his hand chairman please
thank you madam chairman um it's just
really a question really about scrutiny
again i mean in as much as do we you
know i absolutely agree
that we should have the right person in
the right job and i think chrissy
heading something like this would be
absolutely the best thing to do
i would just just from ignorance though
really do we
also scrutinize exactly what
vulnerability
or is there already sort of guidelines
in who is actually
one person or is that sort of issue
there's not and i'm going to cut
councillor morris off at the past i'm
afraid because i know this is something
that he feels very passionate about and
can
talk probably how long have you got
councillor bassinger is the answer to
that so
i'm going to give you the brief answer
if it's all right with council morris
which is
no and that's something we need to look
at that i would see as part of the
scrutiny item
am i correct councillor morris
you are madam chairman thank you very
much for that there is no
legal definition of vulnerable um we
have
uh i've gone to the you know the trouble
of finding out
certain uh authorities um views on
vulnerability
for instance the police i've got the
police one it's contained in peel
i'll send you that out um we've also now
um got the uh you're already working on
the scrutiny item counselor maurice
i'll do this later on but
i'm just going to say that this
indicates the passion and the knowledge
that council morris has around this
issue
and for that and i think we need to use
that in the most efficient way possible
can i come back man chairman just ask if
you can briefly
cancel just again though so would we
be setting a benchmark sort of
nationally i know we're doing this
internally again i'm gonna stop you
councillor passenger because you're
getting into the scrutiny item itself
which just shows what a good scrutiny
item this is and how important it
is that it's already arousing so much
interest and
and concern amongst members so i thank
you
councillor messenger i'm going to move
to councillor morley
now please that's the morning yeah
um thank you chairman it was just do we
have i'm not sure if it's in the
scrutiny
if it's the right one but do we have a
number of percentage of people
vulnerable
who are who are struggling or
again you're moving into the scrutiny
okay
but sir again thank you so i think we
have councillor fleming
you're muted councillor fleming
thank you chair i just wanted to say
that just broadly
um i would agree uh with you that
uh the member the lead member could be
somebody
that that raises that item because it's
obviously something that they have
knowledge on they have an interest in
and and they feel strongly about so and
also
i i understand um cheryl's point about
pet projects but the
i think that's the purpose of the
working group isn't it it goes to the
working group and then
they they look at it i don't know if
four or five
members look at it and say yes or no and
so that
that stops pet projects so i
personally don't have a problem with it
thank you
thank you very much um councilor morris
that's really helpful
um can i go is that counsellor
councillor mays a hand
that was it a legacy hand no it is a
another question madam madam chairman
um could i perhaps propose an amendment
to our um uh
uh uh recommendation
um in that the item i think it's little
two
appendices b um i propose that
uh we put in there that this will be led
by councillor morris
on this occasion and uh uh not by
councillor mays
um would anybody second that
all right i i would like to second that
if i may please madam chairman
thank you councillors mays and bassinger
um if i can just go to uh
cheryl before i go to you councillor
morris um
do we need then to actually amend the
part of the procedure which
uh states that the new lead member will
be neutral
and does that require a proposal please
if i could
it doesn't require an update it's you
know the for all of these items the lead
member will be decided or
we decided that it doesn't need a lead
member um at each committee meeting
and so it's down to the committee to
decide that
excellent so thank you before we go to
uh a vote on um
councillor morris being the lead member
then i'm going to you crack councillor
morris
thank you chair um i would like to be
the lead member on this one um i do
have quite a lot of experience with it i
uh obviously i've brought this uh
this item to the overview and scrutiny
committee and
i do believe that whilst um having a
neutral member on some items of scrutiny
will be a benefit
but it shouldn't be one-size-fits-all um
it's not always the case that we need a
neutral member
it should come to the overview and
scrutiny and it should be debated
and discussed and worked on and a lead
member should be agreed on
um in this case due to you know my
passion and my experience
um i'd love to be the lead member uh
this is uh
this has got me written over it all day
long so um
i'd thank members if uh you know i could
get your support on that one
thank you chair thank you very much so
um
again cheryl do we need to take the
amendment separately or can we
um take the whole thing as one proposal
i think yeah if the committee's happy
that that's the
adjustment then obviously you can um
agree the report but with that amendment
if that's what someone wants to put
forwards
thank you um well i would like to put
that
put that motion forward if i have a
second that we accept the uh
repeat with the amendment stated do i
have a seconder
councillor oh councillor maze
councillor thank you
brilliant so uh do we um do we need to
vote on this or are we happy to go
buy a cent members
agreed agreed three that's fine
i think that's a marvelous thank you
very very much for that
excellent so that moves us on
to agenda item
nine i believe which is any other items
of business that the chairman decides
are urgent of which there are none
so um the item 10 is closure of the
meeting
members thank you very very much for
your contributions this afternoon
or evening i now draw the meeting to a
close
at 6 26 pm
and as the meeting is now closed members
are advised not to enter into any
further discussion on this forum
and to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you